agravando agravando é bom não aguento
mais não vai acordar de madrugada é como
qualquer ser humano para trabalhar me
tira poder planejar o negócio da
rachadura já acerta na privada eu
desisti vou tentar dormir aí meu celular
não está no silencioso porque eu sou
muito pesados e ninguém me acordar eu
entrei em coma a não dar chance ou para
alguém me ligar de manhã eu acordar aí
eu dei essa desgraça fica tocando e não
pára de tocar as desgraças beleza eu fui
lá ver o que era mortes apitando beleza
para ver mensagens gatza pinino do céu
se eu fosse contar a quantidade de roupa
e periquito combinou a sap se juntasse
tudo a povoar a perna do falante vi de
sexo e paul de ong amor com tanta roupa
explicar você o que acontece as pessoas
queriam os grupos de [ __ ] e joga a
gente tenta impedir o povo vai
compartilhando merda e do rola e
periquito é pq nem imagina o nome feio
da [ __ ] vagem vagina também parece nome
de peças de carro né que foi quebrou
irmão e ver quem tem conceito é ó que
morrer a rússia na vagina e beleza o
povo vota nesses grupo ea gente sai de
noite quando é de manhã a gente já está
em mais 500 grupo traria essa desgraça
mas que prolifera e chegue pau e roleta
e que agora imagina se eu não vacilo e
mãe pega uma só a paz minha mãe por
acaso das fotos ap eu acho que até a
quinta geração da minha família na
sequência na qual uma etapa lapada que
eu vou levar pra aprender no tecnosinos
ela saiu lhe perguntam culpa no tempo
que essa desgraça fica botando aí nesse
dia desses grupo e então gente me botar
no nicho não mostra esse grupo não
imagem bem se pra ir pro céu eles
olharam as fotos da asap nintendo que
não passar na atmosfera tanto a [ __ ]
que temos a ver se estão ligados a cada
foto deputado insiste em nada sabe oque
caiu no colo de satã na outra corrida
acontecendo muito é o seguinte foi só
deixar para trás o vida de tanta gente
vê só tem uma menina que estão lá não é
fazendo sexo aí o menino que quer ser
transam é que se o bonzão ele filma
porque hoje em dia aparentemente
transacto no filmar é porque o prazo em
que filmava eu não acho que a empresa
nunca transei sede oca pai a menina
pegue deixa o cara filmar o cara vai
mostrar o amiguinho
é tão aí o vídeo deu transando com minha
namorada aí o menino é o transam pra mim
não transam vou mostrar que eu transando
com a minha pela isaps joga por do
vineyard zapping o vídeo se espalha pela
zap o caminho na fae a menina fica
sentida e tal como aconteceu alguma
coisa a família dela e tal se mata e
suicida com a gente não faz isso mas não
vem eu vou dar aqui uma dica faz menina
para isso nunca mais aconteça
preste bem atenção para seu filho nunca
mais vazará no ataque e tentar lá né
foi é ou não hoje é o novo está lá está
alguns meninos e thala e tal i a filmar
aqui basta a cor branca quando você vê o
menino com celular filmando você fala
assim não pega tão gostoso o trânsito na
balada para eu fazer um [ __ ] rápido
só porque o negócio para que uma chuva
que rápido não só para o seu negócio aí
quando você for colocar a boca lá será
assim arrancar a cabeça da romã dele vir
para cá é fácil para ninguém que ele tem
uma barraca aí eu quero ver o vídeo de
alguém se espalha na chapa agora não
resolveu seu problema deles o rapaz não
vai mais comer não vai mais comer mas
ninguém na terra nunca mais vai filmar
ele fazendo relação nenhuma galera não
então ela não fala mais se firmam no
bota nesse grupo não por favor pelo amor
de deus muito obrigado pela atenção dos
senhores e até mais